Ronnie Jackson Donald Trump's former
Doctor Who is now a congressman
is using Joe Biden's recent skin cancer
to attack him
this is really disgusting these people
know no limits and we knew that I mean
Donald Trump made fun of a disabled
reporter right early in 2016 and then we
knew it was going to get pretty ugly
here is Ronnie Jackson appearing on Fox
news with Maria Bartiromo using Biden's
a cancerous Legion Legion to attack Joe
Biden take a look and Biden had a
cancerous lesion removed from the
president's chest last month uh the
doctor said that this is a common form
the lesion tested positive for carcinoma
but he's okay but I wonder about the
conversation about his capacity you have
been talking about the president's
cognitive abilities being a national
security risk tell us more
well look Emery I'll start by saying
that Biden is the cancer you know he's
what needs to be renewed removed not the
uh not the lesion they found but this is
just another effort from his physician
and from his medical team to distract
they're going to invite in this is ugly
this is ugly ugly stuff this guy's a
doctor first of all I know he had skin
cancer but what about his cognitive
abilities Biden really is the cancer
there is nothing too low for these
people and you know I criticize the
electorate regularly let's put it that
way
I think this is even too low for most of
the electorate I know that there are
some Maga people who will love this and
they'll say there's nothing wrong
nothing inappropriate there's nothing
disturbing or offensive about this I
know that there is that group but the
reality is that for a lot of Americans
even many Republicans they're not going
to go for this this is this is truly not
for them and Ronnie Jackson does this
stuff at his own Peril that's my view if
you disagree with me let me know in the
comments